person liz in your experience what are
the reasons
people as a professional in fitness what
are the reasons people quit
or don't continue on and how does this
address that
when i work one-on-one with people the
biggest thing that
causes them to fall off is either they
don't see progress
or they have a lack of motivation or
they just can't find time which is
number one
hey i don't have time i don't have the
money anymore
whatever it might be this is able to be
in your home
you can wake up go get your strength
training workout which is much different
than a cardio workout
cardio you get better at cardio if you
do more cardio you're going to get
better cardiovascularly
yes but you might not necessarily
necessarily improve your body
composition
you might not necessarily improve your
strength your ability to
reduce your risk for injury so this
here is going to be a game changer and
allowing people more access
more time which is huge because by the
time you've
parked gone in to see your one hour
trainer to take in a shower come back
three hours right it's three hours yeah
absolutely absolutely and what about the
gamification what are your thoughts on
that
because that doesn't exist currently in
workouts right you don't gamify
and give people stars when they come
work out with you do you think that's
going to have an impact on people the
competitive nature of this
and doing it with your friends well it's
definitely fun to work out with me in
person so
let's just make that clear so it's kind
of like a game but for this one
to be able to give them a score of a
strength baseline
and to have them be able to see that
increase
is going to be huge so to have people
if you were to watch a video online a
boot camp video online perhaps you're
not going to know if you're getting any
better
how are you going to know if you're
actually lifting any more weight or if
that weight is going to be appropriate
for you and so
by enabling this strength baseline score
and giving people a strength baseline
we can not only set appropriate weights
reduce risk for injury
we can also notice and notify them when
they are
getting better when they're getting
stronger yeah exactly awesome
well thanks so much for showing it to me
um let's talk a little bit more about
the company actually
i'd love to show yours i'd love to show
you liz's scores oh yeah
when you do your strength assessment the
first thing you get is a report
uh these are the three magic numbers for
liz this is what she gets to see her
progress with over time
this is her upper body score her core
score and her lower body
what does it mean this is this is a
normalized score for up for all of the
upper body movements in our library
uh there are hundreds of movements in
our library and this is this is a
normalized score for upper body core and
then this is lower body
it lets her see the relative strength
between her body parts but also over
time as
as these numbers change she'll see where
she's making making the most gains
uh for more of the fitness nerds uh
these numbers are one rep maxes for the
four exercises that listed
uh and uh and where's the chart that
shows me going up and to the right
we've got to add some charts here
overall she has to she has to do more
workouts
got it all right so that's uh this is
this is kind of our baseline today and
then over time
she'll see that that progress are you
gonna add like inputs for this
because i know fitbit and then the
scales that fitbit makes and we and
those other people
if you added the scale to it you could
have another input of the weight
the fat lean muscle mass is that going
to be an input that's one of the big
drivers behind
us having a mobile app is it allows us
to pull on on a lot of that information
so with apple with the health kit you
could tell that
if you can find out how much someone
slept last night maybe you wouldn't give
them such a heavy squat
that day things like that what about
heart rate i didn't know i noticed no
heart rate in here
ah is heart rate is heart rate important
we actually heart rate is very important
we have two heart rate sensors built
into the machine
so we have an ant plus receiver and a
bluetooth receiver
so you can put on one of those chest
straps or something absolutely add it to
that and that will give you some
indication it gives us additional
additional information about how you're
doing
and because our workouts uh incorporate
both strength flexibility and
intervals the heart rate piece is really
important for the interval exercise and
i saw the leaked documents on the 2.0
that you're building
so i wanted to address that is it true
this will be the front door of a
refrigerator and you have to do the
workout in order to open your
refrigerator in the second version
yeah there's going to be protein shakes
inside and yeah you know i heard that
you're doing something with uh
refrigerator companies that would be
amazing this is just
extraordinary i'm blown away it's very
beautiful great industrial design did
you do the design yourself you used a
firm
uh we worked with uh dan hardin over at
whip saw to do the design
yeah beautiful and we've been working on
this for three and a half years
all right let's hear a little bit more
about the company i'd love to show you
one more thing
and one more thing one more okay go
ahead steve jobs uh one more thing
this is 29 pounds of load right yep but
if i hit this button
it goes oh you tell me there was a
button there's a button on our
intelligence button did you just click
the i give up button it's actually not
the i give up bun it's the let me get
into position before you load me up
oh so so clever that the life
that's always the pain in the neck liz
when you have to like then
get in position then pull the cables
over you can pull your back or something
yeah so that the cable machine you
bought at home for five thousand dollars
uh it would be pretty an idiot be pretty
hard for you to do a squat on that
machine
right but with this with no weight on
the cable i can get into position
and then when i'm ready i'm gonna hand
this to you okay
when you're ready i can hit the button
and then it
just loaded me up with 50 pounds of
force got it 49 actually i can do my
squat
and then i hit the button and it unloads
me with a cable machine this would be
pretty
hard